In the biblical story of the Tower of Babel,...
...all of humanity once spoke a single language...
...until they suddenly split into many groups unable to understand each other.
We don't really know if such an original language ever existed,...
...but we do know that the thousands of languages existing today...
...can be traced back to a much smaller number.
So, how did we end up with so many?
In the early days of human migration, the world was much less populated.
Groups of people that shared a single language and culture often split into smaller tribes,...
...going separate ways in search of fresh game and fertile land.
As they migrated and settled in new places,...
...they became isolated from one another and developed in different ways.
Centuries of living in different conditions, eating different food...
...and encountering different neighbors turned similar dialects...
...with varied pronunciation and vocabulary into radically different languages,...
...continuing to divide as populations grew and spread out further.
Like genealogists, modern linguists try to map this process...
...by tracing multiple languages back as far as they can...
...to their common ancestor or protolanguage.
A group of all languages related in this way is called a "language family,"...
...which can contain many branches and subfamilies.
We may never be able to determine how language came about...
...or whether all human languages did in fact have a common ancestor,...
...scattered through the babel of migration.
But the next time you hear a foreign language, pay attention.
It may not be as foreign as you think.